some people in the Philippines are
reportedly defying a mandatory
evacuation order even as the experts
warn of a massive eruption as soon as
today as a drone footage shows - all now
looks less active but the danger below
the surface still points to a very
serious threat there Ramey Inocencio Xin
C long that's south of Manila with more
on the story
ramie what are you seeing sure
good morning basically towns and
villages across this region are still
dealing with ash that's caked on
vehicles just like this you can see how
difficult it is to get it off these
these tricycles and these cars but it's
also being caked along the homes around
here and we're also even breathing it in
as the winds pick it up but businesses
those have been closed and scientists
are warning everyone here that to all
volcano not too far from where we're
standing right here could be on the
verge of erupting in the next few days
if not the next few hours
fake volcanic ash blanketed entire towns
caked roads in slippery mud and covered
acres of farmland turning this normally
packed tourist hub into ghost towns of
gray - all volcano continues to belch
ash and steam and nearly 500 earthquakes
have rocked this region ever since
Sunday officials warned an eruption
could be imminent nearly 40,000 people
were forced from their homes and took
shelter in these evacuation centers some
even fled with their livestock but the
United Nations says as many as half a
million residents are still at risk a
lot of people are looking at the volcano
and saying oh not so much to see here
it's not true our instruments are
telling us that the significant volcanic
activities are still undergoing and the
threats still there research specialist
dr. Winchell Sebelius says observing the
volcano for the next few days will be
critical the high number of volcanic
earthquakes the fishing's of the
observing around the volcanoes basically
Dahl volcano is telling us that the
magma is still coming out towards the
surface basically the bottom line they
were telling me is don't be fooled by
what we see at the top yes that's
correct
yeah
and I've been wearing this mask waiting
to speak to you guys in large part
because this ash that's blowing all
around us really is hazardous to
people's health a lot of people actually
don't have mass the people we've been
talking to over the past few days but
this is protecting us from little
microscopic crystalline structures
inside and if you inhale it people
really will be severely affected Tony
all right let me get that mask back on
we appreciate a good coverage there in
the Philippines
you